هذه وحدة عسكرية تابعة للدولة السورية
تقوم بإعدام مدنيين غير مسلحين معصوبي
الأعين ومقيدين
عبر حفرة إعدام
ثم حرق أجسادهم
وملء هذه الحفرة في
[موسيقى]
لذلك
[موسيقى] لقد
رأيت الكثير من الفظائع التي تم تصويرها
بالكاميرا ولكن هذا الفيلم على وجه الخصوص
صدمتني لأن قلة من الآخرين لديهم
الاستعداد الذي
يسير به هؤلاء الضحايا نحو موتهم
التأكيدات التي تم إعطاؤها لهم بوضوح
أنهم محميون
بدلاً من
إعدامهم ثم في بعض الأحيان السخرية منهم
قبل وفاتهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق  ]
ما نأمله هو أن يبدأ هذا الفيديو
وغيره من مقاطع الفيديو التي قد تظهر في
إضفاء بعض الإحساس بالعدالة للآلاف العديدة
من العائلات التي لا تزال
تبحث عن أحبائها الذين ما زالوا
لا يعرفون ما إذا كانوا "  إذا كنت في سجن
أو في قبر أو يحتمل أن تكون في
حفرة إعدام مثل تلك التي نراها
في هذا
الفيلم الرهيب
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
إذا لم تكن جريمة حرب ، فسيكون من
الصعب جدًا فهم ما الذي
يمكن أن يشكل حربًا بالفعل  جريمة
[موسيقى]